the brewmaster of course is a magical
person
hi i'm garrett oliver author of the
brewmasters table and brewmaster of
brooklyn brewery but today i am here to
answer your questions on twitter because
this is beer support
[Music]
at dogs and baseball love that
ass
what are hops and no i'm not googling it
i just want someone to just tell me it's
like okay i'm the guy to just tell you
so these are hops the hop is a green
pine cone shaped flower it grows on a
vine in this country largely in the
pacific northwest and when that hop cone
that little flower grows out that is
where you're going to develop all your
flavors and aromas now here's an
interesting fact the hop is the nearest
botanical relative to cannabis this hot
flower you have resins and those resins
are giving you bitterness they're giving
you flavor they're giving you aromas
hops are varietal like wine grapes there
are about a hundred varieties of hops
available on the market right now some
of them taste floral some of them smell
like citrus some of them smell kind of
dank there used to be a lot of spices
used in beer but the hot became
often the only spice in beer because it
also acts to the growth of
bacteria and bacteria can spoil your
beer and so people started to notice the
more hops you add the longer the beer
was going to last and so hops became
really the focal point for bitter beer
flavors at james 241
473 7
asks how do you make beer without yeast
sorry james you can you have to have
yeast in there to ferment your sugar
into alcohol and to make all the flavors
that we associate with beer you can use
other things besides yeast like
bacterial strains etc but you've got to
have yeast to get the job done at
ziermann asks is beer chemistry hmm well
beer is chemistry beer is also biology
beer is also art wine is easy right you
got some grapes grapes have sugar you
stomp on them whatever else they might
start fermenting by themselves and you
have wine beer is tougher we're starting
with this there's no sugar in barley
malt you have to break down the starch
in this into sugars which you do in a
porridge called the mash the natural
enzymes that are in the malt break the
starches down to sugar then you have a
formulation is it going to be dark is it
going to be red because it has fruit in
it is it going to be kind of a caramel
color like that and that's a bit more
art and then you have biology because
you're going to add yeast which is then
going to consume those sugars and give
off carbon dioxide flavors and of course
alcohol there's also a lot of cleaning a
lot of plumbing so you have to be ready
to wear a lot of hats if you want to be
a brewmaster
so at yoff jackson asked how do you
become a brewmaster because i feel
that's an awesome job hashtag dream job
the broodmaster is essentially the chef
of the brewery there are two main ways
you can learn to be a brew master one is
you take classes sometimes for years or
you can do it the old-fashioned way
which is the apprenticeship you
basically attach yourself to
another brewmaster usually for years and
you slowly learn on the job there are
many many jobs in each brewery but in
each brewery there's only one brew
master the same way that there are a lot
of cooks in a kitchen but there's only
one chef at the smarmy swami asks does
jamaican viagra really equal guinness
plus peanuts mixed in a blender i don't
think that would make me very frisky i
prefer my guinness and peanuts
separately
i don't know why you didn't put them in
a blender but guinness does have a
reputation in the caribbean and in
africa for
giving people extra potency i don't know
if there's any truth to this i just
think it tastes pretty good but uh there
is a thing especially with the stronger
versions the guinness far and extra
stout at about eight percent that's
supposed to be really good for you they
think that it's an aphrodisiac and it's
going to give them special powers i'm
not sure i just think it tastes good
at biophilias asks and is home brewing
illegal no but it was
so after prohibition people were really
worried that there were going to be all
these people fermenting at home and they
were not going to be paying taxes my
grandfather was one of them during
prohibition who was making his own beer
at home in the 1970s president jimmy
carter signed legislation making home
brewing legal in the united states you
can brew your own beer at home and you
can drink it and you can bring it to
your friends the thing you can't do is
sell it you got to pay taxes you need
licenses etc etc so yes you can brew
legally at home but no you can't sell it
to all your pals at susan arlene asks is
there such a thing as boxed beer and if
not why not no and the why not is
because carbonation you need to hold the
pressure in your container and a box
doesn't really hold pressure at sparkly
june asks how do you make your own beer
well it's kind of like asking how do you
make your own pancakes right you can get
a box mix just add water just add milk
or you can make pancakes from scratch
kind of the same thing with beer you can
start off with a kit but if you want to
have more control you're going to start
here with the original grains you're
going to crush them you mix them with
hot water at very specific temperatures
about 150 degrees fahrenheit activate
the enzymes you're going to break all
those starches down into sugars you're
going to strain those sugars out bring
it to a boil now you have a liquid
called the wurtz w-o-r-t you bring that
to a boil you add your hops you cool the
whole thing down and you add the yeast
the yeast then it's going to eat the
sugars give off carbon dioxide give off
flavors and give off of course alcohol
within a few days you've got beer i was
an amateur brewer for for years we're
we're going way back i am 400 years old
i didn't like the offering of beer that
we had in the mid-80s at that time so i
started making my own beer at home and
it turned out my beer was better at
reddit beer asks hey reddit beer what is
the weirdest beer you've ever had i've
had all kinds of beers one of the
greatest beer experiences i've had but
the strangest in flavor was drinking the
traditional south african beer uncumboti
out of a communally past sort of
galvanized steel bucket outside of cape
town south africa and it was sour it was
funky it had all sorts of stuff going on
it was made from sorghum but this is a
really traditional beer style beer was
invented probably about 10 000 years ago
by the time you got to ancient egypt
they had everything they had beer styles
they had names they had advertising old
egyptian cities like thieves were
actually built on beer money the
pyramids were built on beer money so
beer goes way way back starting in
africa and then spreading all over the
world at greg mercy exile ask question
for beer twitter why do belgian german
and french brewers predominantly use
glass but in the uk most craft and
microbreweries use cans is it a case of
cost versus tradition in the old days
the only people who could afford a
canning machine were the big brewers so
if you wanted to buy a canner it cost
over a million dollars as the craft beer
movement started to take off people
making canning technologies said we
should make some stuff for for these
guys too and they started to make
canners smaller and the kinetic
technology got better it didn't affect
beer flavor the way that it used to the
beer can eventually became from a
technological point of view equal to the
glass bottle a lot of people feel that
the can is more ecologically friendly it
goes more places that might not allow
glass like say a stadium the belgians
don't use many cans but in the uk and
the united states the can is really
taking over if we're using bottles we
put beer in a brown bottle why because a
brown bottle is going to block a lot of
the light coming in but it can't block
all of it a can however can block all
the light and that is one way in which a
can is actually superior to a bottle
these days when run properly both
packages are pretty much equally good
even though i kind of feel better about
a bottle in a certain way but that's
because i'm 400 years old you know i'm a
traditionalist at lamb
asks how do you make beer from pumpkins
you cook the pumpkins you mash them up
you mix them together with the grain in
your mash the enzymes from the grain
break down the starches the pumpkins
into sugars and you ferment the whole
thing together often people will add
some pumpkin spice because people like
pumpkin spice but pumpkin beer is
actually hundreds of years old at hedwig
gray malk says remember last year when
the republicans were crying that if
biden won he'd make them drink
plant-based beer well you know my beer
was always plant-based so that's one of
those weird things like uh gluten-free
vodka like vodka doesn't have any gluten
in it
at dell boy 1978 uk asks how do beer
makers keep their yeast going how do you
grow yeast yeast is one of the most
important elements in beer it is the
agent that actually takes this sweet
liquid called wort and transforms it
almost magically into beer and there are
various types of yeast the mean one that
we're using in beer is called
saccharomyces and saccharomyces means
the sugar yeast or the sugar fungus it
consumes sugar gives off alcohol and
that's the thing that it does it does it
everywhere in the natural world
including in our beer when you add the
yeast it starts to reproduce and it
reproduces by budding so you have like
one yeast cell here and another one
starts to grow out of it and this
happens over and over again until you
have a full population of yeast now when
the fermentation is finished usually
we'll cool the tank down and the yeast
will drop to the bottom at that point
you can remove the yeast and store it
for later use you can't store it forever
but you can easily store it for a week
or more and you got to keep them healthy
because basically when you're a brewer
that yeast is your partner we like to
joke that we're just basically here
working for the yeast it's the yeast
that are actually doing all the work
they make the beer we make the word and
together we get it all done at dadman
walking asks what's the better coffee
for sunday morning a stout or a wheat
beer the best coffee for sunday morning
is coffee
however wheat beer is going to be better
with breakfast at rambo cowboy asked any
good seafood and beer pairings my first
book the brewmasters table was about
beer and food pairings and i can tell
you there are lots of good beer and
seafood pairings my favorite though
probably is belgian style whit beer and
a really nice salmon in like a lemon
butter sauce i have memories of sitting
on canals in amsterdam drinking that
beer and eating that food
and it's just so spectacular but seafood
and beer absolutely at t gwin asks how
do beer people taste the difference in
ipas i had a mango and an orange and i
couldn't taste anything different ipa
means india pale ale india pale ale was
the most rigidly defined beer style
virtually of all times this was a type
of beer that was brewed in england and
sent to colonists in india beer was not
an entertainment it was a staple food
product many people drank it from the
time they got up in the morning until
they went to bed water could kill you
but beer was always safe and these days
it doesn't mean that much it usually
means that the beer at least has some
real hop aroma and it has some at least
reasonable bitterness somebody can put
mango or orange in the beer too that
happens but uh you want to check the
label because you never know
drink my social asks
pale ale ipa what's the difference
between an ipa and a pale short version
intensity so you're talking about pale
ales usually five to six percent
traditionally ipa was stronger more
bitter drier and more aromatic with hops
but really
you can almost think of ipa as an
intensified version of pale ale at game
quotes app asked ale or mead
wonder boy in monster land arcade it's
gonna have to be ale for me there are
two main kinds of beers ales and lagers
ales are warm fermented lagers are cold
fermented they're two different species
of yeast they have slightly different
flavors ales tend to be more fruity and
more complex
need is fermented honey you add some
water you ferment it with yeast and you
end up with mead first time i ever
actually got a buzz in my whole life
right after high school it was legal
back then to drink right after high
school mead at a renaissance fair i
admit it
both those things happen i drank mead at
a renaissance festival and i'm wearing
this jacket i'm not ashamed at los tacos
314 asks what makes an ipa new england
style
basically
haze haze and a big fruity tropical
flavor is something that really came out
of new england about 10 years ago at
orboros asks shopping for beer how many
different ways can you mix wheat and
hops wtf here's the thing there's not
just wheat and barley and hops and spelt
and emmer and all the other grains that
you could use you can also roast them
very lightly roast them until they are
dark like coffee beans you can
caramelize them you can flavor them in
different ways you can then decide
you're going to add spices so not only
hops suppose you want to add ginger you
could add fruit when we judge beer at
the great american beer festival we
actually judge beer in over 100
different styles so if you're looking at
the wheat and the barley and you're
saying to yourself how many ways can
this really be recombined these beers
must be the same
not true
they can all be really different i can
mix them infinite ways at caroline on
crack asks is the craft beer and spirits
movement threatening big brands the
short answer is yes
but there's no reason for you to be
threatened big brands make their kind of
beer and that's all great but there used
to be all kinds of beer we had one of
the most vibrant beer cultures in the
united states in the entire world but
then prohibition kind of squashed
everything until maybe the late 70s
early 80s we had a monoculture
essentially one kind of beer with
different names on it so now our beer
culture is super creative and it's
drawing from belgium it's drawing from
germany it's drawing from the uk and
also from our own homegrown traditions
so you are living in a nirvana of beer
today but remember that we always had
good beer in the united states we just
forgot for a little while andy hank asks
anybody else climbing a mash tun today
thankfully no i did not climb in a mash
tun today a mashed ton is basically you
crush this you mix it with hot water you
make the porridge that's gonna break
down your starch into sugars that vessel
is called a mashed ton a ton is like a
pot and i didn't climb into one today
but i used to climb into him a lot when
i was younger it was pretty mucky work
at madnessnut asks so british pubs lost
lots of money for having to dump barrels
of outdated beer
sad
yes the traditional british style of
beer actually finishes its fermentation
in the cask it's called cast condition
beer and you need to serve it out within
three or four days once you've reached
it if you don't serve it out that fast
it can turn sour and flat and nobody
likes that so it is a thing if you don't
take care of your beer you might have to
toss them out at joyra artificer asks
are hazy ipa's just beer for people who
would rather be drinking juice but want
to say they love ipas
yes
basically if you don't like big bitter
beers you could still go for the hazy
juicy style and
you know have your fruitiness but not so
much bitterness at our ourwilliams3 asks
with fda laws so tough how do beer wine
liquor makers get away with not listing
the ingredients what's really in my
adult beverage that is a good question
the answer to that is that we are not
allowed
to tell you what is in the beer to a
certain extent it is strangely not legal
in the united states for us to publish
for example nutritional information even
if it's 100 true people worry that in
the alcohol context you might try to
gain advantage by saying that your beer
is safe full of vitamins even if it is
one of those things that's just a weird
thing about united states laws if you go
to some other countries you might be
required to actually put those things to
the label and i think it would be a
pretty good idea at patton smith's says
these anti-ipa tweets
peaked in 2015 who even makes super hot
forward ipas anymore everything is hazy
fruity citrus log off twitter and learn
about beer nerds i think we might learn
to be a little bit more inclusive here
there are a lot of people who like the
hazy fruity juicy modern version and
people who like the traditional sharp
version drink what you like that's the
most important part of beer we're here
to have fun
[Music]
it's pretty good stuff